SPEAKER: I'm just so honored
and privileged to introduce
Betty Soskin.
BETTY SOSKIN: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, [? Anna. ?] Hello.
When I first came into the
parks, I actually-- well,
I guess where I wanted
to start is with a film.
You can imagine the
kind of challenge
that women faced
by our filmmakers
when they were asked
to do the orientation
film for our park, which
represented probably
the greatest
mobilization of workers
since the building
of the pyramids
or the Great Wall of China.
This was Franklin Delano
Roosevelt's great Arsenal
of Democracy.
And every man, woman,
and child in the country
was involved in some capacity.
They say it took
seven people at home
to support each life on the
home front, on the battlefields.
So our filmmakers,
though consigned
to coming up with a
15 or 20 minute film,
decided for us that
they would not do that.
What they did was they
did two complete films,
one 24 minutes that tells the
story of the national effort
across the country.
Because, of course,
we're not a local park.
We're a national park.
And that film is called
"The War at Home,"
and it's a 24-minute film.
And then they did a number
of fragments of films
because there were so many
aspects to that homefront story
that there was no
way to deal with it.
There was a story of 120,000
Japanese and Japanese-Americans
interned, lost two and a
half years of their lives,
and much of their
treasure; the story
of African-American migration
out of the Southern states;
the story of
women's emancipation
into nontraditional labor
for the very first time;
story of that great
explosion at Port Chicago,
which vaporized two Kaiser
ships to the loss of 320
men, 202 of them being
black dock workers.
There were so many
stories so that they
did fragments of
films that we could
use as conversation starters.
But the one that
I use because I'm
in the theater three
to five times a week,
and I'm there using a film that
limits itself to telling just
what happened in the city
of Richmond, because that's
the only part of
the story that I
could talk about with
any kind of authority.
Because that's the
history that I lived.
I was a 20-year-old
clerk working
in a Jim Crow segregated union
hall in the middle of Richmond.
And the story that this
tells-- this film tells--
is about that city during
those years of 1942 to 1945.
So after the film is
over, I'll put my life
into context of that
history for you.
As the credits
roll, you're going
to find my name among the
consultants to the filmmakers.
Of course, the reason
that that list is so long
is because everybody
on the staff
was a consultant
to the filmmakers.
And not only that,
but I didn't have
any idea what a consultant
to a filmmaker was or did.
So there was no
way for me to get
a sense of what this finished
product was going to be.
All I knew was that over a
two and a half or three year
period, every now and then,
we'd get a block of text
to be wordsmithed.
Or we'd get stills from
the Library of Congress
or the National Archives.
And I'd say, OK.
But I was really
in over my head.
I had no idea what this finished
product was going to be.
And when it was finally
released to us, just
before the opening of
the visitor's center
and I saw it for
the first time, it
may interest you to know
that I was disappointed.
I didn't like it at all, partly
because the history as I had
lived it was nowhere in sight.
I was really here.
I was here as a
20-year-old clerk, working
in a Jim Crow segregated
union hall, somewhere
in the middle of Richmond,
in a temporary building
because the unions,
the labor movement,
wasn't yet racially
integrated and wouldn't
be for another decade.
So that in order to comply
with the wishes of Kaiser,
the unions had created
auxiliaries which
was a fancy name for Jim Crow.
There was one at
Marinship at Sausalito.
There was another
in West Oakland.
There was a third in
Richmond, and that
was Boilermakers Auxiliary 36.
And that's where
I spent my days.
You you'd asked me, I'd
have told you at the time
that all the shipyard
workers were black.
Because the only
people I saw where
the people that came to my
window to get their addresses
changed on three
by five [INAUDIBLE]
cards, which is what
I was doing to save
the world for democracy.
And as you can see, it worked.
[LAUGHTER]
But I was nowhere
near the shoreline,
nowhere near a shipyard.
I never saw a ship
under construction.
Nor did I ever see a
ship being launched.
That entire history
had been lost to me.
I came in every day in a
carpool, went home every night,
having no sense of that
bigger picture at all.
If you had known me
two years before then,
you'd have known little
Betty [? Charbonet ?],
who was a little Cajun-Creole
child who'd come out
from New Orleans in 1927.
That was the year that the
city fathers in New Orleans
had chosen to bomb the levees
against the rising Mississippi
to save St. Charles Avenue and
upper-- the Garden District.
And they sacrificed the seventh
and ninth wards and the Treme,
which was our ancestral home.
In that year, my mother had
arrived at 6th Street Station
in Oakland with three
little girls and everything
we had left in a couple
of cardboard suitcases
to join Papa George Allen.
This was her father.
He had already come.
He was out here since
the First World War
and was working as a waiter in
downtown Oakland on Clay Street
and living on 76th Avenue in
a little shotgun bungalow that
was shared with my mother's
two brothers and a sister,
and Aunt Louise, who was
his third wife that we were
no longer calling grandmother.
She was Aunt Louise.
And we would wait
there for my father
who would join us in
a couple of months
when things were
settled in New Orleans.
And I would spend my childhood
and my adolescence in Oakland,
East Oakland, as a child of the
service workers' generation.
Our fathers and our
uncles were the red caps,
and the poor importers, and
the waiters, and the cooks,
and the janitors,
and the laborers.
Our mothers were $0.50 an
hour domestic servants,
taking care of white
people-- children and white
people's homes, because
that's who we were as a nation
in those years.
I graduated from
Castlemont High School
with only two opportunities
for employment open to me.
I could have worked
in agriculture,
or I could have worked
as a domestic servant.
My older sister Marjorie, who
was a beautiful young woman
and a talented
artist incidentally,
spent the first five
years of her marriage
as half of a domestic team.
Her young husband
was the chauffeur,
and Marjorie was the housekeeper
for a family in Piedmont.
And by living on the premises
with Thursdays off, which
was traditional, they
could save every penny
they earned for the down
payment on their first home.
And this was a
traditional pathway
into the middle class
for African Americans.
This is what my life
would have been.
This was the prescription,
except that there
was a third choice.
And it was the one I
was wise enough to take.
I married Mel Reid whose
family had made their way out
from Griffin, Georgia at the
first cannon shots of the Civil
War.
And Mel, his father,
and his grandmother
were all born in Berkeley
General Hospital.
And in 1942, Mel was
in his senior year
at the University
of San Francisco,
playing left half back
for San Francisco Dons.
And what 19-year-old
wouldn't prefer that?
Which is what I did.
So I escaped the life
that my sister had left.
But I share that
history with you
in order to
illustrate that being
a clerk even in a Jim Crow
segregated union hall in 1942
was a step up.
My folks were proud of me.
I was being a clerk.
I wasn't taking care
of white people's homes
or white people's children.
I was a clerk,
which in 1942, would
have been the equivalent
of today's young women
of color being the first in
her family to enter college.
Because that's who we were as
a nation back in those years.
Now, scroll ahead with
me to 15 years ago.
And 15 years ago, I'm
back in Richmond, back
after over 20 years as
a suburban housewife,
after raising four
children to adulthood,
after outliving two husbands,
and after lots and lots
of decades of learning
lots of lessons.
And now by 15 years ago,
I'm pretty sophisticated.
And I'm back in Richmond this
time as a field representative.
Remember the California
State Assembly?
I'm working with Dion Aroner.
And when Dion term
limited out, I
stayed on as a
field representative
for her successor,
Lonnie Hancock,
whose only now term limiting out
of the California State Senate.
I'm in a one person
satellite office in Richmond
and doing constituency work.
And with the rest
of field staff,
I'm helping to determine
what kind of legislation
might be needed out of the five
cities of West Contra Costa
County over which my office sat.
And if you're
wondering whether I
became a genius between the
time I was 20 and 15 years ago,
may I quickly assure you that
that's anything but true.
This was not a case of
personal achievement,
not for one minute.
Nor is it a case
of black history
to be remembered as such.
That arc of my life
from 20 to 15 years
ago illustrates how much social
change occurred in this nation
over those intervening years.
And that's something
that we all did,
all of us, black
and brown and yellow
and straight and gay and trans.
It's what we all did,
all of us, all of us.
Some of us did it kicking
and screaming, and some of us
are still kicking and screaming.
And all of us didn't get
there at the same time,
not by a long shot.
But enough of us completed
that complete arc
that my life so well represents.
To this day, social
change initiated
in those years
between 1942 and 1945,
that exhilaration
of social change,
continues to radiate
out of the Bay Area
into the rest of
the nation, which is
enough to build a park around.
Now, it didn't mean that
we all got there together
or that some of us
didn't freeze in place.
A lot of us froze on issues.
Open housing took a
lot of folks not ready
to have their families
living with the family that
didn't look just like
theirs right next door,
you know, worried
about property values.
And then more of us peeled
off on the decision of "Brown
v. the Board of Education."
Why should my children
be bussed across town
to suit your social agenda?
And then more of us, either
because they had forgotten
or had never known, that it
took $47.25 a week to support
a family of five if you
were white-- our fathers
and our uncles were all
members of the service workers'
generation, and they
earned $25 to $35 a week.
Pullman porters earned
$18 a week plus tips.
And that's what initiated
the first thoughts
of affirmative action.
It was never a case of quotas.
This is what we're doing.
Now, long about 1970,
maybe just before that,
there began to rise in the
Department of Interior,
in the National Park Service,
a sensitivity to the fact
that though every single
taxpayer in the country
was funding the creation,
the development,
and the maintenance of
this incredible system
of national parks.
It was only the people
with the leisure time
and the financial
resources who could afford
to visit them, only that.
And they began to see
the need for urban parks,
taking parks to the people.
And in the city of
Richmond had come
into being one of
those urban parks.
And the planners
were gathered here
to determine the shape of that
park, because each of them
was made of whole
qualths-- each of them
had to be designed
without patterns to go by.
This park had been
created, legislation
carried by George
Miller, supported
by Dianne Feinstein
and Barbara Boxer,
had come into being defined
by scattered sites that
lay throughout the
city of Richmond, sites
that we either owned
privately, commercially,
by nonprofits, civically.
We would own nothing.
How do you create a park
without any federal lands?
And that's what we
were being asked to do.
How do you create a
national park that
doesn't have any boundaries?
The only one that
vaguely resembled
it may have been the one
in Lowell, Massachusetts.
But in that case, the
federal government
had gone in, purchased
the textile mills,
transformed them into
arts and cultural centers.
And over time, the entire
city of Lowell, Massachusetts
became a national park.
That's one model.
And here, with the planners
gathered here, in my district,
in an area where I was not
even aware of a national park,
though my office-- that
little satellite office--
was less than a mile
from the Rosie Memorial.
But it had not occurred
to me to ever connect
to visit the Rosie
Memorial because that
was a white woman's story.
The women in my family had been
working outside their homes
since slavery, because it
had always taken two wages
to support black families.
So I didn't see
any relationship.
That was a white woman's story.
But when the community
meetings began
to be organized because those
owners of those properties
had to be met with-- the
community had to be met with--
to make those decisions along
with the planners of what shape
this park was going to take.
And this was when I met
the national parks, based
on my first PowerPoint, where
I saw for the first time
that incredible, incredible
building, the Ford Assembly
Plant that was designed
by Albert Kahn,
built between the
years of 1929 and 1931,
to assemble Model A Fords.
It was taken over during
the war and turned out
thousands and thousands
of tanks and jeeps
for the war in the Pacific.
But that building
had been constructed
on state-owned land--
built on air rights, one
of the earliest that
used that concept.
And I'm the only one in the
room that represented the state,
and therefore incorporated,
at first informally
as a consultant, but
I'm the only person
of color in the room
and the only person
who can look at the PowerPoint
and instantly see them
as sites of racial segregation.
Because what gets
remembered is determined
by who's in the room
during the remembering.
There was no grand conspiracy
to leave my history out.
There simply wasn't
anybody in that room who
had any reason to know that.
Unfortunately, for all of
us, all of those planners
were graduates of
"Sesame Street."
And in my pantheon of
civil rights leaders,
there had always been
a place for Jim Henson
and his children's television
workship and Mr. Rogers.
Because they spent
several decades
humanizing America's children.
And by 15 years ago, those
kids were all grown up.
And by then, they're sitting
around corporate boardrooms
throughout the country.
They're in the forestry service.
They're in the State Department.
They're in the
national parks service,
Department of Interior.
Now they're in Microsoft,
and Apple, and Google.
And they all knew it
wasn't easy being green,
and they knew that one of these
things is not like the other,
and it doesn't matter one bit.
And they were not only
willing but anxious
to know what was missing
in their PowerPoint.
And for the first time since
I was that 20-year-old clerk
working in that Jim Crow
segregated union hall,
I'm in a position to learn
the rest of this story.
It was a marriage
made to heaven.
I read everything I
could about Mr. Kaiser.
The studies-- the
doctoral theses,
the master's papers-- were
just beginning to come out.
The University of California,
Dr. Spivik, Professor
[? Litvak, ?]
Margaret Archibald,
they were just beginning to
come out and available to us.
And I could, for the first time,
learn about Mr. Henry Kaiser,
and immediately fell in love.
I mean, here was a man
that dropped out of school
at the age of 13, only had
an eighth grade education,
came into Richmond as
a cement contractor
who had never built a ship.
He had to go to the library
to find out how you do that.
He was a man who had such
confidence in himself
that he knew that if he simply
introduced the mass production
techniques that Henry Ford was
using in auto manufacturing
that he could revolutionize
ship building.
All he needed was enough hands.
And he didn't care
what color they were,
and he didn't care who
they were attached to.
He just need enough hands.
And nothing I ever
read about him
would have suggested to me
that he was a social reformer,
not by any long shot.
He was simply a
smart industrialist.
He knew not only
that, but he knew
where the greatest
pool of available labor
existed in this country,
in the five southern states
of Mississippi, Oklahoma,
Arkansas, Texas,
and Louisiana, whites coming
off the Dust Bowl, blacks
recovering from the slow
mechanization of cotton--
everybody bouncing from the
Great Depression of the '30s.
Possible for a black
man to be standing
on the sidewalk in
Jackson, Mississippi,
where Southern tradition
would demand that he step off
into the gutter if a
white person approached,
and that man could be
tapped on the shoulder
by a Kaiser recruiter
and find himself,
two weeks later, in
the city of Richmond,
riding in the front of the
bus 10 years before Rosa Parks
would refuse to give up her
seat in Montgomery, Alabama.
Into a city with a
population of 23,000, only
Henry Kaiser would
have the audacity
to bring in a
workforce of 98,000
black and white
Southerners who were not
going to be sharing drinking
fountains, schools, hospitals,
housing, any kind of public
accommodations for another 20
years back in their
places of origin.
That's not going to
happen until the '60s.
We're talking 1942.
And there's no time for focus
groups and diversity training.
They've got to cut it.
They've got to negotiate at
the individual level every day
in order to get through it
without killing each other.
These are black and
white Southerners.
And because they're all
living under the common threat
of fascist world
domination, there's
no time to take on a broken
social system, no time
to do anything except take on
the mission of their leader,
which is pure and simple-- build
ships faster than the enemy can
sink them.
And together,
together, behind a man
who referred to the bow of
the ship as the pointy end--
you've got to love
Mr. Kaiser-- they
completed 747 ships in three
years and eight months.
747 ships.
By way of comparison, Mr.
Moore at Moore Dry Dock, who
was a traditional ship builder,
had been building ships
since the First World War,
Mr. Moore completed 100.
Bechtel Corporation
completed 93 at Marinship.
And Henry Kaiser and his
merry band of sharecroppers
completed 747 ships
and right here
in San Francisco Bay
outside of Richmond.
They helped to turn
the course of the war
around by out-producing
the enemy.
And in the process, they
accelerated the rate
of social change
so that to this day
it's still radiates
out of the Bay Area
into the rest of the nation.
This is still where
the visionaries
come define constituencies
for their wildest dreams
because of what
happened right here.
That's rather amazing.
They say if you'd dropped
a quarter on the deck
at that time, it would
be welded into place
before you could pick it up.
[CHUCKLING]
It began to occur
to me along the way
that if we had a place on
the planet where we could
go back and revisit that era,
not by the myth that we made up
about it-- you know, none of
that Greatest Generation stuff
or today's American
exceptionalism--
but if we could go back and
revisit that era in truth,
as it was lived by those of us
who lived it, what we could get
is a baseline against which
to measure how far we've come.
But we have to know
where we started.
We have to know in order to
find out how far we've come.
And that became my reason
for becoming a park ranger
at the age of 85.
Because that history was so
important and so forgotten.
It is so important that
today's generations know,
because we still have
a long way to go.
But we have to
know-- and in knowing
is the hope for the future.
And I like to end my talks
giving you my personal history,
which is rather remarkable,
if only because it
was lived by so many.
It's not mine alone.
But my great-grandmother, Leon
[? Teanbro ?] [? Allen, ?] was
born into slavery in 1846 in
St. James Parish, Louisiana.
Enslaved until she
was 19, at which time
she was freed by the
Emancipation Proclamation.
Mary George [? Allen, ?] who
was a corporal in the Louisiana
State Colored Troops, fighting
on the side of the North
in the civil war,
together over time,
they brought into
the world 13 children
in their home in
St. James Parish.
My mother was born to
their eldest son George
and his 14-year-old wife who
only lived until my mother was
seven months old.
But my great-grandmother
lived to be 102,
dying in 1948, three years after
my experience in that Jim Crow
union hall.
My mother was born in 1894
and died at 101 in 1995.
And I was born in 1921 and
will celebrate my 95th birthday
in another 10 days.
And that means that
the three of us
were all adults
at the same time.
I was 27 years old,
married and a mother,
by the time my
slave ancestor died.
I knew her as a
matriarch of my family.
And all of that American
history-- from the Dred Scott
decision, the Civil War,
Emancipation Proclamation,
Reconstruction, "Plessy v.
Ferguson," Sacco and Vanzetti,
Rosenbergs, Lindbergh's
flight, Amelia Earhart's loss,
the First World War, all the
way to Martin Luther King
and Malcolm X, and Fannie
Lou Hamer, and Emmett Till,
and House on American
Activities Committee,
and Kent State, People's
Park, to September 11th,
and Occupy, and Michael
Brown, Trayvon Martin, 20
kids in a Connecticut
classroom and 14
in San Bernardino, nine people
in a prayer circle in North
Carolina, in Orlando,
Florida-- all of that
happened within the
lifetime of three women who
were adults at the same time.
And add to that the fact
that on January 20th of 2009,
I'm the seated guests on the
Capitol mall, guest of George
Miller, my representative,
with a picture
of my great-grandmother
in my breast pocket,
witnessing the
inauguration of America's
first African-American
president.
In the shadow of the
Lincoln Memorial, Lincoln
whose life was
contemporary with the life
of my great-grandmother,
that's how fast the time goes.
If that doesn't blow your
mind, check your pulse.
[CHUCKLING]
Because that's how
fast the time goes.
I know how my generation
met the threat of its day.
It was a very real threat
of fascist world domination.
And I know that we did that
under a severely flawed
social system.
But we nonetheless
prevailed, and our children
and our grandchildren-- and
some of you in this room
are now facing a new threat.
The threat of fascist
domination may be passed.
But the threat of
rising sea levels,
global warming, climate
change, are with us now.
And they will have to-- you
will have to-- match and exceed
that great mobilization in
order to save the planet.
And you're going to do it under
a still flawed social system.
Because the nature of democracy
is it will never stay fixed.
It wasn't intended to.
We have a constitutionally
protected right to be wrong,
protected right to be bigots.
We also have this incredible
system of national parks,
where it is now possible
for us to revisit almost
any era in our history--
the scenic wonders,
the contemplative places,
the heroic places,
the shameful places,
and the painful places,
in order to own that
history that we may process
that history, in order
to move into a more
compassionate future together.
And that's what the national
parks has come to mean for me.
There's a place
on the film where
Agnes Moore, a Rosie,
still living, says,
"It was the greatest coming
together of the American people
that I have ever lived through."
And when she first
used to say that,
when I would stand
against the wall watching
the faces of the audience
watching the film,
and I would hear her
say that, and I'd
think, how could she say that?
Come on, Agnes, that's crazy.
That's not true.
And somewhere around my 90th
birthday, I aged into a place
where the concept of
conflicting truths dawned on me.
And I realized that we
all create our own reality
and that there are many,
many truths, and many of them
are in conflict.
But this is not an
either/or world.
It is both/and.
And I wished I'd known that
when I was a 14-year-old.
But that's what
the park has come
to mean to me, the place where
those conflicting truths can
coexist.
So thank you very
much for coming.
I thank you very much.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: My question
has to do with what
you think is the greatest
migration of people
coming together,
given that there
are these different realities.
I'm just curious--
BETTY SOSKIN: I
didn't understand.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about Rosie
the Riveter saying this is the
greatest migration of people
coming together.
BETTY SOSKIN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'd
like to know what
you think is for you-- your
own personal reality-- what
is that greatest
migration for you?
BETTY SOSKIN: I think that
that coming together was not
an aware coming together.
We came together
out of an emergency.
And we did it under a
completely broken social system.
So it is remembered
in different ways
by different blocks of people.
It is nostalgic for the Rosies.
It is the proudest day that
some women that I work with
can look back on.
And it is not that.
For the coming together does not
represent that for me at all.
Because I grew up in California.
I grew up as a second
generation Californian, not as
an African-American.
And because that
was true, I wasn't
equipped for the great
migration that came in.
Because inadvertently,
Henry Kaiser
imported the entire system
of racial segregation
along with those people.
And I was in a world
that I'd not grown up
in without leaving home.
And so the coming together
has mixed messages for me.
I think that maybe
that will always be.
I think people come together
in different configurations
at different times.
AUDIENCE: You shared
some great stories
and personal recollections
of sort of-- every generation
we have challenges.
And you hit on that at the end.
With all of the
experience that you
have through the life
that you've lived,
do you think we-- [LAUGHS] what
are our shots in the future?
Do you think we'll be able to
rise to these new challenges,
from what you've seen?
BETTY SOSKIN: Yeah.
I think that every generation
has to recreate democracy
in its time.
Because it's a participatory
form of governance
that requires all of us.
And the 39% turnout in
the last general election
does not bode well for our
ability to even sustain
ourselves as a nation.
The ways in which I am glad that
my time is coming to an end,
because I have no idea what
you guys are going to do.
[LAUGHTER]
We are leaving behind a mess.
[LAUGHS]
But it is true that the power to
recreate democracy is with you.
When I was in grammar school
or even in middle school,
I really believed
that the Constitution
with the Bill of Rights
was an entitlement that
came with me at birth.
And my outrage in the '60s as
an African-American activist was
based on that belief
that this is my rights,
and you cannot take
it away from me.
And I somehow evolved
to a new place
where I now see them
as not deeds at all
or entitlements
but as blueprints
with which every generation
has to recreate democracy.
That's all they are.
They were dreams and visions
of the Founding Fathers.
And each generation
has to reshape it.
And the tools for
reshaping it lie
in those founding documents.
And that's something that I
couldn't have known, I think,
when I was even 75.
That's come in with
recently acquired knowledge.
I now see myself as
an evolving person
in an evolving nation
in an evolving universe
that I couldn't have
said when I was 75.
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
BETTY SOSKIN: Thank you
very, very much, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]